all right and we are live who's this
fine gentleman I'm talking to you right
here okay nice so what's your role
Sebastian in reference to production OCD
with the UI stuff like that now must it
mix I've had my eye on this for a little
bit so tell me a little bit about
phantom doctrine what's the premise oh
[Laughter]
wow okay let's get into it
[Music]
okay
to make the game playable extended once
you finish the game go again and then
you get some additional intricacies the
story
gotcha what's been going on now that
that extended mode unlocks in those
features that's cool that's cool so
basically you have the ability to start
with a different faction so just be
completely and now each one affects the
game differently or just like you get it
from a different perspective
the beginning and go different missions
agonist that's very cool
that's very cool that's cool let's get
it torn I can put my real name in yeah
you put Lord kognito Paulo Coelho Rd in
a space that see og og NIT oh I do yeah
now one more one more hole with the hole
there you go now you got it yeah I mean
are you what's the big deal what's the
big name okay alright
yeah man let's get into it
Wow engine looks really good even what
wood engineer you guys using for up and
real core nice nice yeah they'll get a
pipe going let's get real yeah look at
the espionage going oh let's do it
aren't you about to see may have been
burned or okay it's getting intense now
so like time period wise like what's the
time period last like uh do you know as
far as I go you know is it like set the
future at about or setting like an hour
past that happened yeah how they're
asking it's the 80s
okay so cold war stories events here you
know which take place in the game are
based and historic stories nice locket
loving that you have in the cinematics
and looks like you're very heavy
narrative driven and I it seems cool now
like that
it's a big Steve yeah use the network
like the art style listening keep
keeping it classic even that looking
even down to computers though incident
loving level of PC
[Music]
[Music]
okay are we getting off with a bang he's
starting off now I'm assuming that's
part of that organization and talked
about those guys okay
into it
so I see three now will we be starting
off the mission or we kind of solo on
this one you won't want to because your
research so just to recap the main this
guy right here he's the main okay and
the other two technically are expendable
yes but I love that I love that you're
actually doing it the fog actually looks
really cool too by the way yeah we could
actually try to take out
soldiers here but we don't want to draw
much attention to what we're doing so
laser barriers I think you need to
disable the security measures okay so
technically right now we're like almost
in a stealth like infiltration
[Music]
like that so you're rewarding that the
stuff player the guy that wants to play
you know in concealment but also it's
turn-based for that now once you finish
your moves the enemy then moves yes yes
yep just just like ex comment
now does he have like okay yes yet does
he have like the arm like the amount of
units as far as in a turn that a person
wears that represented like as far as um
the amount of movement we don't know
where this is man we got it we got to be
stealthy
okay let's go
take your down as you can see this enemy
is facing me mmm all right we didn't
kill nice and I see that's an optional
thing right there disable the bat laser
Balducci just objective but you just
completed we don't want right makes the
mission much harder
Hey
in turn we could use snow at this point
I think we're we're good
okay so that was something like you were
looking at equipment that you would
think about buddies now can pre-plan any
of that stuff as far as the equipment
before the mission yes oh nice nice nice
now what I'm going to ask you I'm not
noticing the enemies like have a field
of radius as far as spotting you like
like how was the alert mechanic work
thing is as you see if I cover the enemy
yeah he has this oh that so that's his
cone of vision okay so did this me I'm
like why are they not reacting to him
okay got it now
so you're in disguise he's just thinking
okay that's just a normal person okay
[Music]
some hazmat suit dies randomly trying to
come in and do some work I like that so
you've got stealth mechanic this guy's
that's pretty cool I like that
okay civilians soldiers that's our
objective police don't have a spirit
action point I think home finish the
awareness which was used to take down
the right dispose of the body just as a
seizure so they can alert that wow wow
cuts okay I like that like the close-ups
as well so it's almost like that
actually reminds me of a scam Isla slum
hit me but you actually have to get rid
of the bodies because that could also
alert them that's very cool okay give
the player more choice more choice
absolutely now what's the maximum amount
of our players you can have on a mission
you know what do we go up to as far as
units that you have on your side during
loadout send up to six agent nitrogen
however there are some systems which
enable for example to get control wow
that's pretty cool
here there is a secondary objective
which could do it
Reisen right now getting that himself
okay - okay okay
gosh so we're gonna break snow we're
gonna get into it now and this is that
breach mechanic okay the missions love
this man like this is a horrible but
it's about Xcover so let's do this
bridge to see what's about
okay so you can choose the weapons we've
had silenced weapons for example mm-hmm
we could do it without breaking stuff
really our silence is you okay
okay alright so they're primed and ready
to go nice I like that I like that he
can't enemy over matzo bricks Wow okay
[Music]
got the intermission and show you these
strategically okay let's do it
what's doing that congratulations to us
we got through we we stealthily went the
rule we got off we got our breach
mechanic going you know we can hit a
body very this is really cool you it's
way more than that though I didn't
realize that she had those additional
elements you know on it man and like I
said breach his next level to me like I
like that aspect I love the stealth and
the fact you can kind of complete a
mission almost in stealth yeah man you
got to do it you gotta go all out with
it okay
[Music]
this is the okay let me ask you a
question I'm noticing these little
things you got circulatory respiratory
what's these about these are deep
primary agents secondary stars like nice
so increase the primary star and
therefore I think the secondary switch
which are used there's a lot of
complexity here there's a lot more depth
Porter's okay oh we can hire the agent
mm-hmm right this is the one from the
mission that we acquired because
information about someone looking for
extra all right so we will record
exactly as you can see the danger level
every time you do okay Wow agent making
money and so on
Wow so this whole thing this right here
this is our base so to speak so when you
say in the danger that they can come
attack actual beta get more okay yeah so
you can I just wanna question on the
base movement how would I in theory be
able to do that okay
mmm and those are all these suspicious
activities going around the world so you
can send your agents to scout these and
prevent for example conspiracy missions
from being completed in that way the
danger go down got it got it got it
okay is that the true agent